bonjour gilbert casasus merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a dit les élections présidentielles
en pologne dimanche très attendu
notamment par l'union européenne et par
les états unis pourquoi un tel intérêt
d'abord il faut savoir que ces élections
semble être jouée il ya quelques mois et
il y à une nouvelle donne politique
salon sur la montre une évolution en
pologne le parti le ps est un parti qui
n'est plus tellement sûr de lui même ou
ne peut plus être sûr de lui même et
cela aussi a range clairement l'union
européenne européenne sait très bien que
la politique menée en pologne n'est pas
de trop près aux européennes et soutient
dire ouvertement le candidat de la plate
forme du monde pratique tâche estime
donc on est dans une nouvelle
constellation
alors ça ne veut pas dire que le pis a
perdu et que tout ça ne sera pas présent
nous sommes dans une nouvelle
constellation lui aussi au fait que nous
d'art vient de recevoir le soutien de
trump mais trump même en pologne les
mêmes tellement aimé qu'il ait ihya
keita est justement pourquoi donald
trump a apporté son soutien au candidat
sortant duda donc no quel intérêt parce
que tout simplement nous da et le
meilleur 40 pieds de la pologne
vis-à-vis de la mairie de 36 mètres da
est un pion dans le jeu européen de
truck c'est un pion pro-américain dans
le jeu européen est donc très bas tout
intérêt à avoir tout à comme président
de pologne ou si notamment dans ses
relations conflictuelles but à côté avec
la russie ce qui est traditionnel mais
ce qui est plus de 9 des cons des
relations de plus en plus difficile avec
l'allemagne daniela mes requêtes
on le disait une
un scrutin attendu également par par
l'union européenne quelles sont les
relations aujourd'hui qu'entretiennent
l'union européenne et l'europe
alors d'abord elle a d'abord il est
clair et net que la pologne est membre
de l'union européenne
il est clair aussi que la pologne a
toujours posé des problèmes ce n'est pas
un pays qui respecte toutes les règles
ou moins qu'on puisse dire en vigueur
dans l'union européenne notamment des
entorses graves au système démocratique
et on a vu et je crois que c'est
extrêmement intéressant
une sorte de relation de plus en plus
conflictuelles entre l'art et plus tard
à l'allemagne et la pologne
ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles sont
mauvaises mais il ya encore quelques
temps elle c'est pas si loin que ça
madame merkel avait le soutien de la
pologne la pologne comptait beaucoup sur
madame merkel
il y avait une relation privilégiée
entre l'allemagne et la pologne
entre-temps cette relation privilégiée
s'est refroidie et par exemple le
spécial et spécialistes allemands
la pologne qui est en place à marc celui
de qui est le spécialiste officiel
allemagne sur la pologne déclaré il ya
très peu de temps dans un grand magazine
allemand qu aujourd'hui la pologne de
viale de plus en plus un allié compliqué
pour berlin alors vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure les élections semblaient presque
joué un aîné encore quelques semaines
c'est avant que l'opposition regagne du
terrain est ce que vous pensez que la
pandémie de coronavirus a joué en faveur
de l'opposition qui a eu plus de temps
pour mettre sa stratégie en place c'est
un des facteurs mais je pense qu'il ne
s'agit pas seulement de regarder ce
facteur là je pense que la société
polonaise évolué plus rapidement qu'on
ne le croit et ça c'est intéressant de
voir que l'un des thèmes de la campagne
c'était lgbt alors dans un pays très
catholique on n'aurait pas pu s'imaginer
encore un ou deux ans que ce sujet
devienne un sujet fondamental crucial où
une campagne électorale pourquoi parce
que l'on note est un phénomène qui te
quelques années je vais moi même
enregistré lors de voyages rôle
que l'alliance liens très forts mis le
peuple polonais à l'église catholique je
ne peux pas dire qu'il n'existe plus
loin de là au contraire une photo très
fort mais il s'est quand même distendus
et donc on a une sorte de laïcisation
alors à une vitesse très très lente de
la société polonaise et l'influencent de
l'église catholique sur les débats
politiques en pologne n'est plus la même
que celle qu'il y avait eu tort par
exemple de jean paul deux mois après
merci beaucoup et gilbert casasus
d'avoir a été avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france rappelle avec vous êtes
professeur d'études européennes à
l'université bilingue de fribourg merci
beaucoup